big news from timcast.com we're back
Tucker Carlson to stream new show
through Twitter saying the news you
consume is a lie you are being
manipulated you know what how about we
just play the actual clip from Tucker
himself here we go
hey it's Tucker Carlson you often hear
people say the news is full of lies but
most of the time that's not exactly
right much of what you see on television
or read the New York Times is in fact
true in the literal sense it could pass
one of the media's own fact checks
lawyers would be willing to sign off on
it in fact they may have but that
doesn't make it true it's not true at
the most basic level the news you
consume is a lie a lie of the
stealthiest and most Insidious kind
facts have been withheld on purpose
along with proportion and perspective
you are being manipulated how does that
work let's see if I tell you that a man
has been unjustly arrested for armed
robbery that is not strictly speaking a
lie he may have been framed at this
point there's been no trial so no one
can really say
but if I don't mention the fact that the
same man has been arrested for the same
crime six times before am I really
informing you no I'm not I'm misleading
you and that's what the news media are
doing in every story that matters every
day of the week every week of the year
what's it like to work in a system like
that after more than 30 years in the
middle of it we could tell you Stories
the best you can hope for in the news
business at this point is the freedom to
tell the fullest truth that you can but
there are always limits and you know
that if you bump up against those limits
often enough you will be fired for it
that's not a guess it's guaranteed every
person who works in English language
media understands that the rule of what
you can't say defines everything it's
filthy really and it's utterly
corrupting you can't have a free Society
if people aren't allowed to say what
they think is true
speech is the fundamental prerequisite
for democracy that's why it's enshrined
in the first of our constitutional
amendments amazingly as of tonight there
aren't many platforms left that allow
Free Speech the last big one remaining
in the world the only one is Twitter
where we are now
Twitter has long served as the place
where our national conversation
incubates and develops Twitter is not a
partisan site everybody's allowed here
and we think that's a good thing
and yet for the most part the news that
you see analyzed on Twitter comes from
media organizations that are themselves
thinly disguised propaganda Outlets you
see it on cable news you talk about it
on Twitter
the result may feel like a debate but
actually The Gatekeepers are still in
charge
we think that's a bad system we know
exactly how it works and we're sick of
it
starting soon we'll be bringing a new
version of the show we've been doing for
the last six and a half years to Twitter
we bring some other things too which
we'll tell you about but for now we're
just grateful to be here free speech is
the main right that you have without it
you have no others see you soon
so Elon Musk responded to all the news
saying on this platform unlike the
one-way Street of broadcast people are
able to interact critique and refute
whatever is said and of course anything
misleading will get community notes I
also want to be clear that we have not
signed a deal of any kind whatsoever
Tucker is subject to the same rules and
rewards of all content creators rewards
means subscriptions and advertising
Revenue share coming soon which is a
function of how many people subscribe in
the advertising views associated with
content not that many others
particularly from the left also choose
to be the content creators on this
platform now I I see what elon's got
going on here we have not signed a deal
of any kind whatsoever that does not
mean they did not shake hands and come
to an agreement because we had this
story from Forbes Elon Musk talking with
Tucker Carlson about working together
I don't believe that Tucker Carlson
would walk away from launching his own
network and making 100 million plus per
year on subscriptions unless there was
some kind of deal in place be it verbal
not a contractual agreement
I imagine that there is probably some
kind of deal in that as they said
there's going to be the subscriptions
and stuff like that and I imagine that
Elon essentially went to Tucker and said
look the money's there blah blah blah
we'll we'll make sure that you get the
reach you have this many Etc this is how
it'll work with the way that we're
thinking and so I can assure you that
you know give you my word that this will
will be and it may be just a handshake
deal like you said
um but it doesn't see I don't see you
know I don't think that that he'll have
a problem coming up with money he's the
the I just think that there's no reason
for anyone to do a show on Twitter
unless Elon makes a guarantee you like
YouTube subsidizes content yeah I think
but the thing is I think that there's a
lot of people I think there's more
people that are like you that the money
isn't you know the issue like Tucker
doesn't understand talking about this uh
with Michael downstairs the the money
like Tucker's already rich he's already
gonna make you know never gonna have to
worry about money in his life so I just
feel like he's looking for
um for reach and for probably security
and I think that the money is a
secondary thing I mean it's not like I
hear about it you know I agree but I
mean money money is secondary you want
to do something good you want to say
what you have to say and you want people
to see it but money is like the the the
oil for the machine fair so I don't
think Tucker is going to want to look at
his net worth his bank account his
assets and back let's liquidate this
property so that I can do a show he's
probably gonna be like how can I fund a
show how can I make money that being
said it may be that Elon simply went to
Tucker and said you do your show on
Twitter we absorb all of the costs of
broadcast
hosting server and everything and so
Tucker might be thinking about it like
okay we'll do subscriptions we'll make
money on Twitter that way Elon says they
only take 10 so what am I really losing
and they're gonna they're gonna cover
all the hosting costs done I just
imagine that that there's there's plenty
of money to be made and plenty of
avenues for him to make money and that
the the essentially the teaming up of
you know the two kind of biggest Free
Speech names going really puts up puts
pressure on all of the other media like
this is the mo this is going to be the
most pressure that all of the other
media Outlets have probably ever
experienced it could be Paradigm
shifting I mean one we don't know what
the restrictions that Tucker has on him
that would maybe prevent him from
discussing the money and revenues from
this sort of content but you know look
at what happened with musk himself he
put a portion of his fortune up to try
to do something good with Twitter
because he saw you know what was going
on with the collusion and and the lack
of speech on Twitter so if we're lucky
we're going to get something similar
with Tucker himself where you know maybe
what what Elon uh is doing with Twitter
they are now trying to do to YouTube and
and kind of create a new paradigm in the
content creator Hub yeah
I mean I feel like that's what I feel
like this is more about the the
conversation that you know the discourse
that's going on the national discourse
than it is about him being concerned
about monetary you know you know how
much money he's going to make because
again it's already rich and these guys
are the dudes that are out there
carrying the torch for actual liberalism
in an age when you've got so many
progressives that are really
authoritarian and really really strongly
looking to you know censor speech and
say this is outside of the the realm of
of acceptable conversation the the
opportunity right now is for anybody who
wants to launch a show needs to launch
it on Twitter right now 100 because
what's going to happen is within the
next year Elon is going to be looking at
propping up whatever shows and content
they have and what elon's not going to
want to do is start trying to poach
outside content because it's very
difficult I would love to have Tim cast
IRL live every day on Twitter I've got
1.6 million followers it would be
fantastic I think we get tremendous
reach it's just difficult to do and I
don't know what the upside is other than
just General reach it's an investment I
understand but it's kind of about a side
out of mind if we invested in
multi-streaming did the show on Twitter
did a live stream or whatever because
they have that capability I don't know
what we would get out of it so Elon
let's say he comes to us and he's like
we want you on on Twitter I'd be like
okay here's what we need to cover the
costs of that hiring somebody to do it
et cetera et cetera if somebody just
launches a show on Twitter right now
when Elon is looking for content to put
in the suggested feed it will be you so
that's that's that's how it always works
when YouTube first started there were
people who made no money and just did it
and then when YouTube started expanding
they promoted those people those people
became rich and famous so
I don't know man Tucker doesn't need it
I'm wondering what the conversation was
let me uh let me pull up what Forbes had
to say Forbes said that Elon Musk has
been talking with former Fox News host
Tucker Carlson about possibly working
together according to a new report from
axios the news comes after Carlson was
abruptly pulled off the air by Fox blah
blah blah they said that axios had
learned that Carlson and Elon Musk had a
conversation about working together but
didn't discuss specifics
I don't know I don't know where we go
who Tucker is as well it's a big
signpost who Tucker is and him coming
here it's it's definitely him his face
and a new turning point for Twitter so
that's that's pretty cool convergence
right there but is this going to drive
the left off of Twitter into places like
blue sky or Mastodon or something
because they're already attacking
Twitter for oh you're gonna host Tucker
you're already taking Twitter saying
you're going to host uh Tucker Carlson
it is interesting he even he even says
that I hope that many others
particularly on the left will make some
comments just look man
elon's light to the party I'm glad he's
at the party but he's late to the party
he posts that Meme of you know the
person the the the left moving further
and further left and then makes that
makes a moderate right wing and it's
like bro that was 10 years ago that
happened 10 years ago and you got to the
party like two years ago yeah we're all
so early though Tim like weird like
people that are plugged in are extremely
early and and normies are just catching
wind to this and I think that you know
the whole covid thing is I mean I don't
wanna I'm a little hesitant to say this
but one of them actually I'll say it
like this one of the uh benefits one of
the the Silver Linings of kovid was it
woke people up to the the control that
the of the narrative from the left and
from the government and it made people
realize the government was really
interested in censoring and really
interested in controlling what is and
isn't allowed to be said so I I
understand your frustration I just feel
like
this is a little frustrated well I mean
I understand your point but I I just
think that this is really we're so ahead
of the curve like and I'm just saying
it's wishful thinking Elon I don't I
think doesn't understand he understands
a little bit but he's new to this the
left is a cult yes we had Lance from the
surfs on this show who admitted I I
asked him okay earmuffs for your kids
I'll keep it family friendly to the best
of my abilities I said if you went into
MGM National Harbor you know it's it's
just south of DC it's this big shopping
center casino and loudly proclaimed what
you previously said previously said and
what he what did he say
let's just put it this way he claimed
that if a if a straight male or I'm
sorry that if a male engaged in adult
activities with a biological male who
was trans it wasn't in fact gay he said
it in a different way much more graphic
much more graphic description and I said
if you ask the average person would they
agreed he said no of course not I'm like
you're in a cult if you believe so
strongly in this world view and you know
no one agrees with you at all like the
majority of the world you are the odd
person out you are on the wrong side of
history and so with that being said I
think Elon doesn't understand the extent
to which the left is in a cult and
unwilling to engage and willing to burn
things down for their cult well I mean
there's definitely truth in that I'll
also add this though I think there is
some fear that people are you know
expressing here about the potential for
left-wing people to leave the platform I
think a lot of people who are True
Believers are pretty far to the left
would leave your average normal
run-of-the-mill left-wing person
probably would not and part of the
reason these platforms were able to get
away with censoring conservatives for so
long is because they weren't all that
afraid of like sort of a small
contingent of conservatives really far
to the right leaving and so I think
based on the same Market principles
there's not that much of a risk of
people on the left leaving well I don't
I don't care if they leave I'm not
saying that they should stay I think
this is a good thing because I think
here's what's going to happen my point
is I think taking Twitter was one of the
most powerful things you could do in the
culture War Elon Musk nailed that yeah
because it's like you're saying the left
dominates the space and so default
liberals fall in line yeah but now with
the left fleeing it's actually a good
thing because that means the popular
accounts the big accounts the accounts
that people want to Aspire to be like
are going to be more moderate to
right-leaning and that means regular
people who are on the platform are going
to see more of that exactly okay I just
want to mention one more thing Twitter
does lean to the left but it's not you
know like Tumblr was where it's just
overwhelmingly left leaning in anyone
who goes there can sniff that out
immediate alien disregard most of what
they're seeing it's deceptive because it
almost seems more moderate even though
traditionally the user base has been
more left-wing but that's been part of
why it's been so powerful as a tool for
framing the narrative on the part of the
left people get the feeling it's
unbiased when it is really uh Center
left but I was going to say I think
there is something to be said about
maintaining the Olive Branch to people
who are reasonable uh and sending the
incentives against the unreasonable
people we want them to leave so that we
can have legitimate conversation but
then you know you've got people out
there like RFK Junior he's on the left
and I think you know he's got some good
ideas and he seems like somebody who
doesn't hate us you know I don't agree
with him on gun control and stuff like
that but he seems like somebody who
doesn't hate us you know you've had
Destiny on this show he's at least
willing to engage I don't agree with him
on everything but he's at least willing
to engage and have the conversation uh
you've got the Jimmy doors of the world
and and you've got the walk away
movement where there is some level of
disgust with the cult mentality uh and
all of that so but I think there's
something to be said about the album The
People you're naming are people who
agree on facts Jimmy Dore he's a social
I think he's a suffering proclaimed
socialist but he's like here's what the
news said and here's what we fact check
and here's what we found out to be true
he can bring that to us and we say yes
you are correct we we've analyzed the
facts and we agree on the facts then our
opinions differ and we're like well
that's okay all of our opinions differ
right you get someone like Destiny who
comes out and says Kyle Rittenhouse is
acting in self-defense and the left
comes after him he may be a liberal but
he's like hey this I watch it I'm not
gonna lie this is what happened and then
the cult are the people who are just
outright lying they will say whatever
whatever whatever needs to be said even
if it doesn't make sense for instance
you might have some left to say
something like a woman should be allowed
to abort her child at any point because
part of her body but she shouldn't be
allowed to do math because that would
intentionally kill the baby which is
just confusing because it's
contradictory in in in in in itself so
that to me is a cult member
yeah I think without the Olive Branch to
reasonable people you run the risk of
doing the same thing that's done that's
done to to the right where like you know
that Meme where
um like the guy is pushed from the left
and there and yeah um you know yeah and
they're like oh yeah are you okay why
are you associating with the right I
think if we don't have that and it's got
to be more less about ideas or or even
political philosophy more about
character
you know and people who are just
reasonable there's a I think there's a
lot of substance to that because one of
the things that I've experienced is just
in my life it has happened to be that
when I interact with with people on the
left I have felt like they're
exclusionary and this is again this is
this is anecdotal I know I unders I
understand that but like if you don't if
you're not welcoming you're not gonna
get anybody on your side like when All
That Remains got our start
the blogs that were giving me the most
crap were the ones that were on the left
so like I'm not going to feel any kind
of sympathetic you know any kind of
sympathy towards people that are on the
left when all the people that are
attacking me are from the left you know
you have to leave the door open and
there's going to be a left wing yes like
no matter what like unless you can
somehow like obliterate the the
connection between personality type and
political Association there is going to
be a left wing and I think I'm going to
promote a left wing that yeah is Jimmy
Dore left wing if you ask the
quote-unquote left they'll say no he's
far right that's insane yes and that's
where we're at so they're they're right
now in this country there are actual
left and actual right who are friends
and having good conversations and trying
to move things forward and that would be
like the Jimmy door and the Tucker
Carlson having that conversation but
what we refer to now as left and right
isn't even political it's cult and not
cult yeah and Jimmy Dore is probably the
best example of that and then to a
lesser degree someone like me right like
moderate centers but they call right
wing well the left will make arguments
like yeah but look at this he voted for
Trump I'm like yeah I did vote for Trump
Jimmy Dore does not like Donald Trump
but they still call right wing that is
that is insane you voted for Trump and
like 15 years ago Trump was a Democrat
right people on the right would have
said he's oh that's left that's their
argument the argument from the left is
when people say I'm a regular I'm just a
regular person from 10 years ago they
say that's what conservative means they
were like uh the argument the left makes
is in night if someone from 1950 in 1970
said you know I'm not uh conservative
I'm just a regular person from 15 years
ago they would say yeah before civil
rights like yes so you are right wing
you are conservative because you're not
with the times or whatever the
difference today is left and right in
the sense of uh our politics cultural
traditional versus uh economic you know
communal systems or Capital systems mean
absolutely nothing Jimmy Dora socialist
is right wing you can you can deviate
from leftist Economic Policy but you
can't deviate from social cult policy
even if it doesn't make sense like when
that dude said you know you can take
math or you can't a woman can't take
math because it'll kill the baby but you
can't kill the baby yeah like that just
it literally makes no sense as long as
he is saying words that align with the
quote unquote left the cult then you're
left that's it even even I think the
funny thing about the whole debate is
Sheamus over here as he often is as the
pro-life guy he's not even saying
anything and me the traditional
pro-choice Guy arguing with the
pro-abortion guy and he's calling me
pro-life right wing well forced birther
and I part of it was I I didn't it's so
stupid I didn't want to Dogpile him but
there were one or two moments I mean
there were a few moments where he said
things that were blatantly factually
incorrect but then when he was saying
incorrect related to health care for
children and trying to justify
mutilation I had to jump in I mean but I
mean I just to correct the nonsense he
was taking no but yeah part of why I was
remaining quiet wasn't because I was
like oh man like obviously you know I
believe this is an incredibly important
issue it's incredibly important to me
but I thought they're having the
discussion and it might be in bad taste
if this was a jumping I'm not trying to
rehash that episode no I'm just trying
to point out that I'm clearly at odds
with you on a lot of these issues as
someone who's like moderate slightly
left leaning on the issue but to their
perspective he's he's equating you and I
together despite the fact that we
disagree which is a huge compliment for
you you know what I mean thanks for
watching this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time